Oh perfect timing I need to go downtown
and get me snacks for Tim don't get
happy - game starting here faster than
delivery with the Hulk's
thing now remember it's for Tim Duncan
so nothing fancy just the fundamentals
come on let's go I'm expecting change
you guys are really nearing up my night
just gonna watch the game I think I know
that guy
finally here we go good evening here oh
you have 508 possible combinations ha ha
ha I can keep that too yeah
son for me my journey retreat what next
mission
we'll call you all right it's not a hug
defenders grab the top quick
all right there yet all right kids good
luck out there big eater you coming
tonight I can't tonight
I got the start internship what's up
guys here's my report for tonight I
stopped the grandstand bicycle hey could
you do me a favor hold on of them if
anybody by oh I help this old lady and
she bought me a churro so I was nice I
just feel like I could be doing more
wait a minute you guys on the real
avenges hope gives it away new move am
working on uh bed
he's working for crazy dangerous mission
cater there people who handle this sort
of thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
world-changing boys timely change to my
dad put my top will you Spanish Queen
you got to get better at this part of
the job I'm intimidated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter
[Music]
I'm just kidding hunger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol because mister
stop treating me like a kid could you
are at him yeah you can stop a boss with
his bare hands
you
you